yo okay you know what else i like in
japan it just goes along with the
nightlife yeah right it's uh the uconn
drinks
uh oh oh yeah did you want to explain
that you can't drink because
that so i should have i should have
bought one in preparation if yeah we can
talk about this
but there's these like tiny little
things like 200 milliliter
cans it's like that yeah it's like a
medicine bottle yeah yeah
it tastes like bubble gum and it's
apparently like ginger like it's
doesn't taste like bubble gum i think it
tastes like awesome i think it tastes i
think it tastes great
smells like ginger turmeric turmeric but
uh yeah that tastes
like i i like do you like it i like i
like the taste yeah felix like the taste
yeah but felix is [ __ ] weird it
reminds me of calpol
that's why i like the taste so
essentially what this drink is
advertised as
is uh prevents hangovers yeah and
everyone in the western world is like
that doesn't seem right i remember well
that was like a scam
yeah when i first saw i was like i'm
pretty sure if it worked
we would have that was my thought as
well like how
if it really works why has england's not
used this before
don't you think the entire budget of the
nhs would be spent on buying this
because
then all of the medical problems would
be sold like i'm pretty sure we would
have it right
yeah i thought and then one day on a
whim i was like all right
fine i'll try it yeah and then it was
like having a shield
on your liver like none of the drinks
got me drunk
yeah yeah and it was like that for the
first few times until i really drank way
too much and then it was like
not drunk not drunk not drunk absolutely
unable to sleep
like not it's so weird it was just like
the 2020 economy it's just like
the coronavirus tank and then you're
[ __ ] drunk
in like an instant because i never tried
it until i tried it with you because
every time i saw it i was like
no that maybe that will work for like
one drink yeah
i don't go to music i don't have one
drink so i'm like no this won't work for
me but then yeah i had it
and it tastes like us i'm like great
this is already a good start
yeah and then yeah i think i was like
four or five drinks you don't feel like
i'm just like
oh my god it's weird the immunity so
like it's it's advertises
like you don't have a hangover but
really i think you it's it's like
formatted alchemist it's like law of
equivalent exchange right okay okay
okay i know what i'm talking about so
like you drink it and you lose your
[ __ ] mother
so you you drink it and you get less
drunk when you're drinking it so you
have to drink
more to get drunk but then the day after
like if you did completely destroy your
body i feel like it doesn't help in
hangover
if you go too hard it doesn't help but
you know those times where maybe you've
had like
quite a bit you're quite tipsy you're
not like absolutely shit-faced yeah it
like
completely stops any hangovers yeah it
completely stops any hangover but for me
it stops that tipsy feeling as well yeah
in my in my mind when it comes to like
whether it gets rid of the hangover the
next morning i feel like a lot of it is
just placebo
where it's just like if i drink this
it'll probably stop it and
i definitely i definitely feel an effect
yeah because the hangovers
the worst hangovers i've had in japan is
when i haven't drank that right
so now i pretty much like you'll never
see me go like drinking without drinking
it now yeah which i don't know if it's a
good thing or not like is my body gonna
get dependent
on it to drink cause like i don't know
anything i i always drink it when i know
i have something to do the next day
it's not bad for you by the way it's
it's literally just like two americans
if anything is
very very healthy it's just a bunch of
like [ __ ] minerals and [ __ ]
like like look at me a monkey brain like
i know what's in it
i'll question this [ __ ] just look it up
and you'll find it
yeah from what i understand it's it's
very healthy it's like a health drink
someone's going to come and be like
actually
actually it destroys your liver it's
like as if the alcohol doesn't already
destroy them
hidden health benefits hidden health
benefits of course
oh